does it represent what does it mean to
you
uh it means a lot just uh you know
coming for
you know eight years in houston and then
you know having a fresh start
with some unbelievable talent and
obviously the coaching staff the front
office
from top to bottom uh the welcome has
been amazing
you know so it's a fresh start for me to
go out there and
ultimately have a chance to compete at a
title
bruce beck nbc new york
hey james what's your message to nets
fans on what kind of
player and what kind of teammate they're
getting
um an elite player an elite teammate um
an elite leader
um and just a guy that's
willing to do whatever it takes um to
rack up as many as we
went as many wins as we can um
sacrifice
brian lewis new york post
hey james uh welcome uh following up on
that i mean
you've proven yourself to be an elite
player and kd's an elite player kyrie's
an elite player all you guys have
had the ball in your hands and been
asked to make big shots
i'm curious how the three of you make
sure that you guys come together
and keep the main thing the main thing
and find a way to gel for the greater
good
chemistry uh sacrifice and and
like you said we're all elite you know
so depending on the game depending on
you know what's going on throughout the
course of the game
that's going to determine who gets the
ball and who makes the plays um
we're all unselfish we're all willing
passers
and we play basketball the right way um
and that's all that matters
otis livingston cbs new york
hey james welcome to brooklyn um from
your post-game comments after the lakers
loss to what your teammates were saying
about you as far as being disrespectful
uh and also you being held out of
practice until a trade was made
it got pretty ugly at the end of your
tenure in houston is there any part of
you
that regressed the way that it ended
it's just i wasn't disrespectful to
anyone
um those guys i just got there
houston i've been there for a very long
time
i've been through all the ups and downs
um you know with that organization
and i wasn't disrespectful towards
anyone you know i just made a comment
you know that the team as as a whole
wasn't good enough to compete for a
title
and you know at the stage of my career
right where i am now
um that's what i would love you know and
so
i wasn't trying to be disrespectful to
anybody um
especially not to the organization and
um like i said just i'm excited to be
here in brooklyn
and um you know excited for a new start
but do you do you regret the way it
ended though i mean it's a place that
you loved and you had so many heights
i regret because i'm not the type of guy
to you know i don't need the attention
especially the negative energy the
negative attention like i've never been
that guy
um you know so there were some things i
felt like out of my character
um but the ultimate goal was to get
somewhere
um you know where i can compete and here
i am in brooklyn you know
i have nothing but love and respect for
that organization
uh that city and everything that i've
ever done for me and my family
much respect malika andrews
espn hi james welcome
um sean mark said yesterday that in
large part because you are
pretty much going to be thrown into the
fire here brooklyn has a schedule where
they don't practice
a whole lot um he's hoping that
you will lean a lot on your previous
relationship
uh with kevin durant what communication
had you had with him in the days leading
up to this and how much do you think
that that's going to play a piece that
previous relationship with both him
and jeff green uh that's a pretty
special piece of lean on
um you know i think
me just loving the game of basketball
and having so much talent around me
makes it easier
i have it obviously having a
conversation with steve
and and mike and the entire coaching
staff and then even the players today
i'm more confident because you know the
things that they do offensively and
defensively are similar to what i've
i've been you know used to in houston so
um
just going out there and being me you
know and and making the game easier for
obviously kevin and when kai comes back
but you know our bigs
our shooters and just being myself um
and that's the most important
thing greg logan newsday
hi james uh welcome to brooklyn uh i i
just like to drill down a little bit
on your thought process even before
training camp
making the decision to uh ask for the
trade from
from the rockets to the nets uh how did
you arrive at that
and was there conversation between you
and kd and kyrie when you guys worked
out
uh in los angeles prior to the season
you know how far
back does this go um as far as with
houston
i'm just one of the after the bubble
after that loss
just wanted to reevaluate my career and
and uh the team
and and the direction that the
organization was going um
and then you look from top to bottom
from uh the
general manager leaving to you know mike
d'antoni leaving
um to reevaluating our you know
personnel and see if we had enough to
compete with the best teams in this
league
and you know as time went on and free
agency and things like that started to
go on it was like
well i felt like we didn't have a chance
you know and so
you know as much as i love the city of
houston love being there i think at the
point of my career it's not about money
it's not about anything else but having
a chance at reaching the ultimate goal
is
you know it's to winning at the highest
level you know so
that's where that came into play um
it didn't it didn't go as smooth as i
would i would love it to go
but i think uh you know both sides are
happy
christian winfield new york daily news
hey james uh
first and foremost welcome to brooklyn
thank you um
i guess you would know better than any
of us in this room that you know winning
a championship is not easy
right you know there's 30 teams you know
of those 30 maybe
five or six have real chances to win it
um you've been part of those five or six
for
god knows how long since you've been in
houston uh you've had multiple runs deep
you've had it with
different players from chris paul
russell westbrook uh mello dwight
i'm just curious as to what gives you
the confidence that this time around
will be different and that this group
can get it done
um i mean obviously you got kevin durant
and kyrie irving on the team
and then surrounded by those guys
um you have really good pieces and
deandre
jeff shooters um and joe
landry um and i mean you just look at
this entire roster and it's built
um for any style of basketball you want
um and then the coaching staff who you
know knows the game of basketball at a
high level
you just add that all together and it's
like uh that's
that's a legit chance right there it was
a no-brainer for me
rachel nichols espn
hey james uh obviously so many great
players go without winning a title
there's guys in the hall of fame without
winning a title
but how about you how do you see your
career in terms of how important it is
to actually win that title to complete
what you want to do in basketball
uh it's not a guarantee to me coming to
brooklyn is you know guaranteeing the
title
rachel but i think for me giving myself
a chance
is very very important um you know at
younger you know giving myself a chance
but
you know wanting to get paid and wanted
to wanting to take care of my family was
very very important to me
now the stage of my career is giving
myself a chance to
do something that i haven't accomplished
yet in this league and that was that's
very important to me now
and that's the situation that i'm in and
that's why
i'm here in brooklyn um i'm excited for
the new opportunity
uh obviously we know it's not easy it's
not gonna be easy at all
but um you know with this roster and his
coaching staff and his organization
i think we have a legit chance
david aldridge the athletic
james um if daryl moore was still the gm
in houston do you think he would still
be in houston
i'm not sure it's a really good question
can't answer that justin walters
pix11
hey james welcome to brooklyn you and
k.d
are much different players than you were
obviously at your time at okc
was wondering how much can you bring
from that experience to brooklyn
and then a two-fold to this is having a
conversation with kai
and making sure that all three of you
can coexist have you had that
conversation already
uh we haven't but you know i think for
us
um it might take a little time it might
not
um i think all of us are very very smart
like i said are very unselfish
and we know what's at stake so
i mean it's just it's a matter of uh you
know coaches putting this in position
and
us communicating putting putting
ourselves through positions
and spots on the floor we can be
effective and help each other out
each game is going to be different but i
think as time goes on since we're not
really practicing
as we get a feel for you know throughout
the course of games that it should be a
lot easier because like i said all of us
are unselfish
and we want to see the next man succeed
not only just us three though we want to
see our entire
team exceed and play to the best of
their ability
howard beck sports illustrated
hey james um obviously when you make a
trade request you can't necessarily
predict
where that's going to go could have been
a lot of different places can you
confirm that
brooklyn was the top of your list why
the nets
and did you consider what some of the
other options
might have been had this gone a
different way um
yeah they were on top of my list but
there were a few team other teams
involved as well
um i mean they could have got they could
have got crazy
but credit to you know the houston
rockets who were
unbelievable organization and um you
know work work with me
as bad as it might look from the outside
uh internally they worked with me
and they made sure i ended up here so uh
much credit to them and
uh very very appreciative
brian mahoney associated press
hey james uh obviously everyone talks
about the sacrifice that you three guys
will have to make and
and sean mark said yesterday you all
said you want to do that uh
my question is kind of how much can you
sacrifice and still be
you know a great player like you are
you've been the best scorer in the
league
the ball's in your hands if if you're
not that guy as much now
are you still you know an elite great
player like you are
of course
taylor rooks bleacher report hey james
welcome
um i know you're obviously still getting
acclimated to this team but when you
look at yourself
and you look at the pieces what parts of
your game do you envision you know
staying the same for this to work and
what parts do you envision
changing for this to work with this team
very good question i think uh
for me my play play-making ability um
we have two elite scorers that the world
knows already
um my job is to come out here obviously
scored a basketball when needed but my
play-making ability
whereas get getting our shooter shots
getting our bigs
finishes around the rim and making it
making the entire team better
um i think that's one aspect of my game
that will
will excel in this offense and um
as long as i'm you know making my
teammates better it doesn't matter about
the points like i think everybody knows
that i can
score the ball at a high clip um and
that's what the sacrifice comes in at
bob windrum that's daily hi
welcome to brooklyn uh james how would
you describe your conditioning level now
at this point in the season great
uh back to greg logan newsday
uh james we all know about your
relationship with
kevin durant long-term relationship can
you go into
your relationship with kyrie a little
bit and how
critical do you think that will be
because you're both
used to having the ball on your hands
and and needing the ball
uh to create the way you each do i think
uh
you know we're really good at it at
creating
and and creating good shots for
ourselves and creating shots for our
teammates
like i said it's all the flow you can't
i can't predict how it's going to go
um kyrie might score you know 10
possessions in a row
you know katie might score 10
possessions in a row like they're more
than capable of that and
i'm fine with that you know because
we're going to be winning and it's going
to be good so
i mean tomorrow we'll see and
it's going to be fun and i'm excited
about it
alex schiffer the athletic
hey james welcome to brooklyn uh
obviously you played against steve
nashua in your career but outside of
that did you
did you have much of a relationship with
him prior to this trade uh not really
not really but just having a
conversation with him today was uh it
was exciting you know obviously he has
that plain guard mentality
um one of the best to ever do it so just
to go over the offense uh
you know watching i mean just him
explaining the offense
you know and positions that he sees me
in and uh
you know where he can use my playmaking
ability was exciting
because obviously he's done it for a
very long time at a high level
ian begley sny
uh james welcome to brooklyn did uh
how much if at all did did mike d'antoni
being here
factor into where brooklyn was kind of
on your uh
wish list entering this thing uh i was
it was a part of it
you know mike's an unbelievable coach uh
you know he
he's been doing it for a very very long
time and
um obviously mike is a factor just being
comfortable with him
being comfortable with kevin uh knowing
kyrie
just just the entire just those four
pieces right there
uh made it easy you know obviously then
being in brooklyn
um you know for me was a no-brainer
brian lewis new york post
hey uh james following up on two of your
answers
i mean do you expect i guess to
facilitate a little more for
k.d and kai uh score less and facilitate
more for them and secondly
i'm not questioning you know your focus
or your drive but when you get questions
about your defense or questions about
your conditioning
do you use those to kind of
self-motivate you know
bulletin board type stuff do you use
that to sell i'm already motivated i'm
as motivated as they come
um i don't really pay attention to the
defense and the conditioning
um because everybody's started the same
as far as like you know training camp
and all that so it doesn't matter to me
i don't really focus on i don't really
pay attention to it
i know i'm one of the best basketball
players that we have in this league so
you know my job is to go out there and
focus on what i'm supposed to be doing
every single night
now to get back to your question as far
as for just facilitating
it just depends on the flow of the game
you know some games i might you know be
a facilitator some some nights i might
got it going
and you know score the ball at a high
cliff that's the beauty of having
uh being versatile and being able to do
more than one thing
um and same with kevin and same with
kyrie
um just depends on every night is gonna
be different
sam amick the athletic
james good to see you um as far as
trying to understand how you got to this
decision you talked about coach d'antoni
and being happy that he's in brooklyn
but i wonder when he decided to leave
you know he'd been in the news a lot we
knew that was a possibility but
did that play a part for you you know
and how did that hit you and within that
uh tillman fertitta and what role if any
his handling of rockets business mata
mata uh yeah when daryl and mike left
uh kind of sat back and kind of
reevaluated everything
you know those are two guys that i was
very comfortable with
uh in their decision making uh for the
organization
you know so once they left i had to
figure out um
was was this organization going in into
a
you know a rebuild stage or you know
were they still trying to compete at the
highest level um
and that was my whole thought process
thank you james appreciate your time
thank you